Blanca can write 256
lines of code in 8 hours.
To solve this,
we should set up a proportion.
So 96 lines of code in 3 hours.
We set that equal to x / 8.
It actually wouldn't have mattered
if we had written this as 3
/ 96 is equivalent to 8 / x.
The important thing is
that we're consistent.
If lines of code is in the denominator
in one of the proportions,
then it should also be in
the denominator of the other proportion.
And then the hours should be
the same for both as well.
But getting back to our original
proportion, let's cross multiply.
We can multiply 96 by 8, and
set that equal to three times x.
96 times 8 is 768, which equals 3x.
Let's divide both sides by
three to isolate x, and
then we're left with x = 256.